Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Yes, now we're actually in a proper, uh, birthday setting now.
So, did you guys enjoy the concert?
Did you?
The one-time showing of that, the, the, the Anime Expo concert version.
I know some of you guys, I saw some of you guys were like, wait, this is like the non-polished version?
Yeah.
Yes, because, um, one of the things that I am planning on redoing is, um, Escape from the City.
I mentioned this before in a previous stream, but, uh, I am planning on redoing, um, the motion capture for Escape from the City.
Because, I talked about this before, but it was because you can sort of tell that we recorded the Escape from the City motion capture thing individually.
Because, obviously, we couldn't... we didn't know how to interact with each other.
Like, Mint did hers in Japan and everything too.
And so we're like, how do we... we have to stand there.
Ha ha ha ha...
So...
We were like, we didn't know how to like, um, how to interact because we don't know where they were, like where the other person was.
And so, um, that's why, like, you can tell, like, we were like, oh man, like, the energy for it is like different from the other...
Uh, obviously the other sets because, like, the other ones, it was like easier to do, uh, for the concert.
Um, that is like one of the things, uh, uh, one of the things that, uh, the sloppiest thing was...
Haha, Joe, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Haha, yeah, yeah.
Um, oh wait, sorry, I forgot, I knew I forgot to include something.
I forgot to include chat in my...
Okay, I was like, yay, I fit everything.
Oh no, okay.
Oh wait, I did, you're right there.
I forgot you're just sitting there.
Yeah, no, chat's broken because I didn't put a new chat in here.
Um, this was from the outfit reveal chat.
Haha, there you go.
I was like, where are you guys?
Oh, you're down here.
Hello, little guy.
Haha, hello, short king.
Haha,
so that is one of the things, um, I'm planning on, um, I'm planning on redoing.
Um, that's why, uh, but I will be adding, like, two new songs in the concert just so it'll be, like, much more worth it.
So there's, like, some things that, you know, because it'll be my first concert upload onto the channel and, like, for the archive and I do want, I wanted Escape from the City to be much more dynamic to match the entire vibe of, uh, the concert.
Um, us desyncing there during the MC portion.
I'll keep that in.
I'll keep, I'll keep that in.
That was pretty sloppy.
Um, okay.
Fun fact.
The reason why Laimoo was desynced from us is because Laimoo was like, guys, I have to do the happy birthday part by myself.
Like, it's gonna mess with me.
Haha.
So, we let her, we let her sing happy birthday by herself, but it desynced with her.
Just like, I, I just, I, at that point I was like, I'm not redoing this.
I, it's just like, give me, guys, give me a sec.
I'm just singing happy birthday part by myself.
I can't sing it with you guys.
So, that's why she's not singed with us.
If you're wondering how the fuck that happened.
I'll keep, um, I'll keep, uh, I'll keep the MC portion in.
Um, hahaha.
So, he's just like, what the fuck?
Why, you, the sing, you're like, no, I can't.
It's gonna mess with me.
Um, hahaha.
Um, and, yeah, so, yes, love me.
So, but yes, there are also like, minor things I would like to fix as well.
Um, you guys might not have noticed it, but like, I know that when it's archived, people are gonna replace it.
And they're gonna play it over and over again.
And they're gonna spot all the little mistakes that, like, was like, ah, no, we can't fix this in time.
Because, um, there's not enough time to fix this.
And, hahaha.
Um, we were telling Mint, count us in when she was the reason everyone was off-tempo.
It's hilarious.
Dogstrings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, that's why, that's why I was like, ah, no, I have to.
Uh, and there's one thing I really want.
This is like, one of the little things.
But, um, one of the things I wanted to change was the light sticks for, um, Escape from the City.
I wanted so that when we were singing Escape from the City, I wanted the light sticks to basically light up to our...
Uh, sorry, yeah, my, my glasses hit...
Sorry, my, let me...
To make it more immersive for you guys.
Uh, my glasses, um...
Uh, no wait.
My, my glasses hit my microphone just now.
So...
Anyway, um...
You know what?
I want...
Oh wait, no.
I don't want to be Dōkittets, sorry.
No Dōkittets for you.
I want tomato time.
So that's why, that's why, uh...
Uh, uh, bu-bub-bub-bub, uh.
Okay.
So I wanted the light sticks to be the colors of our... of our Oshi... I guess, like, not Oshi, my colors, like, of our colors in general.
So, um, that's what I wanted for Escape from the City, but we couldn't change that in time, because, like, it requires them to separate the programming for the 3D stuff.
So, I thought it would be a really nice touch to have, like, the light sticks to be, like, our colors.
So, like, you know, each... it's, like, each of our fandom is... each of our fans in our fan commute...
Like, how... are you probably the Doki Bird fandom?
But...
So, I thought that was gonna be really cute.
So, it's, like, just, like, some things I really wanted to improve on.
And, uh, for, like, you know, I'm a perfectionist, and I just really wanted my concert upload to be, like, really good.
And now you guys sort of know why I was so fucking tired almost every day, and so busy almost every...
It's over.
The evil has been defeated.
It's finally over.
Now you guys know why I was so fucking tired every fucking day, and exhausted.
But I...
But I still had to work, because I shall reveal...
I shall finally reveal how much this concert cost me.
And then I was... I thought it was very expensive.
But then I was told that, like...
I was, like, on the lower end.
And I was like, that's lower end?
Now you understand why people don't give concerts for free.
Why there's, like, streaming tickets and, um, you know, why tickets are so fucking expensive for, like, 3D concerts and everything.
Why this is usually, um, why it's usually not free.
So, like, you guys are technically gonna get a free concert.
Uh, but to be fair, the production value for mine was pretty high quality, I would say.
I would say the production quality was very high quality for, like, what I got.
Like, uh, for, like, uh, what I paid for it in general.
Um, because, like, I feel like my concert was, like, basically on par with, like...
You can sort of say, like, the quality of...
Even for a month!
If you think about it!
For a month's work?
The fact that it was a month's work and, um...
It was able to be, like...
Like, the quality of it was sort of, like, you know...
Like, around, like, corporate level was pretty impressive to me.
I was like, holy fuck.
Like...
And it was just a month of work from there.
Um...
But, basically...
I shall finally...
Let me...
Let me be Dragoon.
I don't know what to be.
Okay, wait.
I got it.
Give me a sec.
I forgot about...
Some people thought I forgot because I did tweet about it.
But, um...
I received this before it got tweeted, by the way.
Um...
Like, I...
Because they were like, oh, yeah.
We just wanted to be sure.
Um...
Guys, I knew I knew about this.
Okay, sorry.
Uh...
Sorry.
If I'm gonna talk about it, I'll talk about it with this.
Alright, so...
Alright.
So...
The concert...
Was...
Forty-eight thousand dollars.
Jingle jangle.
Jingle...
The funny thing is that I don't know what Chad is reacting to.
It could be for the money or it could be...
For...
For the...
Jingle jangle.
Jingle jangle jangle.
Jingle...
Jingle jangle.
I told you.
Sports bra.
Oh, that's right.
My sports bra was working overtime.
Wow, that's a big number.
Next thing...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yes.
So...
Um...
For those who don't know why they have this...
This is actually a birthday present from some of the dragoons.
Some of the dragoons...
Uh...
Did this as a birthday present for me.
So...
Uh...
Salia sent it to me.
I was like...
Surprise!
The strongest sports bra in the world.
So...
Um...
Uh...
Gian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's a lot of...
Money.
The surgery was a success, guys.
Where... Where is she?
I need to... Where's the dragon?
I need to talk to them.
No!
Anyway.
But this was a birthday present from the dragoons.
They actually contacted my mama and my papa.
To, like, basically give... Make sure... Make sure what it's like when I take off my sports bra.
So... This is the... The birthday present for me.
Nice.
Hey, guys.
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
So, yes.
This is now my... I can do this now.
I can take off my sports bra.
What if I get demonetized?
I've never had that happen before.
I don't know.
Is this demonetized?
Is this demonetizable?
I don't know.
Okay.
All right.
Back to...
Back to... Going back to school now.
We're gonna go back.
We're gonna...
Uh... Can you put on a scarf?
Tokey!
Coward!
Anyway.
So, um...
Uh...
So, yes.
Um...
It was...
$48,000.
And...
Um...
And I have to pay more because I'm polishing...
I'm getting, like, stuff redone.
So, it might be, like...
$50,000 later.
Uh...
But...
Um...
That's why...
Remember when Naimu was like...
So, do you get...
Do you get, like...
Do you get anything out of doing this concert?
And I'm like...
Do you get, like, money?
Ha ha ha!
What do you...
What do you mean?
Ha ha ha ha!
You mean...
I lose money.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Um...
Full-on American dollars.
Yeehaw!
Uh...
Great Googly Moogly 4.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So...
Um...
It was our money, guys.
Because...
Without your support...
I wouldn't have been able...
To, uh...
Do all of this.
And be able to, you know...
Do a concert.
Like, this in general.
Um...
And...
You know...
It was also, like...
A test run...
With this...
Uh...
3D production team.
Because...
I will be...
Stop...
Stop wasting our money!
Ha ha ha!
Did you not enjoy the concert?
You can't say that.
You enjoyed the concert.
The moment you opened that concert...
You can't say that to me.
Like...
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
So...
Um...
Anyway...
So...
This was a test run...
Because I will be...
Using them for my official...
Um...
3D debut.
I know you guys are, like, saying, like...
Isn't...
Wasn't that your 3D?
No...
That...
I...
What I see as an official 3D debut...
Is not just a concert...
It's more like, you know...
More like a...
I guess like...
A...
A show, I guess.
Like...
A celebration of sorts.
And...
What I mean by that...
I want to have, like...
More so of not just, like...
You know...
Singing and dancing.
Um...
I want to, like...
You know...
Like, it's like a...
Showcase.
Yeah.
Showcase variety show type deal.
So it's not just, you know...
Singing and dancing.
So...
Um...
More than just a concert.
So, I'll be using them in the future for my official 3D debut.
Because that was, like, the one thing that had the most trouble.
Was trying to find the right 3D studio to do it.
And this was, like, my test run with that company.
With their... with their production team.
So, yes, I will be, like, working with them in the future.
I don't know.
I feel like it might be much more expensive.
Because I want to add more, like, a variety show element.
You know, playing games with people.
Like, you know, like, those little... little, like, games and stuff.
Not just, like, dancing and singing.
And that requires, you know, more setup for things like that.
So, um... but yes, that's what I'm going to be saving up for.
Saving up for next.
In terms of, like, my expenses.
But I'm... I'm gonna chill a little bit.
I'm gonna chill.
That was, like... like... a lot.
That was... a lot of money that I spent.
But thank you, guys.
I really appreciate all the super chats and the support.
Like... like I said, without your support.
And without, like, you know, you guys watching me.
And, like, um... being here with me.
I couldn't have done this without you guys.
Uh, of course.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Ticket fees.
Yeah, like I said, like...
Now you guys sort of understand why, like...
These concerts are very expensive.
Now...
Now you understand...
Uh, how... why...
Why, like, getting to watch these...
Like, usually, you know, like, official concerts like these...
Um...
Uh...
Is, like...
Very expensive with, like...
Even when you have to buy streaming tickets as well.
Um...
But...
This concert will be free when I upload it here.
And I'll be adding more stuff to it.
Um...
Uh...
Cooperate.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Ticket fee here.
Happy Doki Day.
Thank you.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Uh...
And...
But, yes.
But, like...
I was very surprised when they told me that...
When I was, like, comparing notes that, like...
Mine was on the cheaper scale in terms...
Not cheaper, but, like, on the lower end.
Despite the quality of it.
I was...
Very, very surprised.
Uh...
Just cause, like, you know...
Didn't exp...
I...
I thought...
I thought that was very expensive already.
But they're like, no.
Um...
My friend was like, no, they can go to six figures too.
And I was like...
I was like, what?
I was like...
Holy shit!
It's six figures!
And then you can tell why...
People do, like, so much merch shilling.
By the way, buy my merch.
My merch...
I...
My merch store is up now.
We have a...
Oh my god!
I got the...
Um...
Speaking of merch...
I got the retro Doki Bird plush...
Uh...
Today.
Like, I opened my door today.
Um...
After the concert restream.
And I found...
Like, I got...
I received the box from...
Uh...
Gamer Subs...
Of the retro Doki Bird plush.
And it's so cute.
Oh...
The photos don't do it justice on how cute it is.
And at first, I wanted to edit the hat to make it smaller.
But in person, it's like...
It's just...
It looks great in person.
So I asked them to like...
Oh, like the edits and stuff I wanted to do earlier.
Like, it's...
I'm fine with it...
Uh...
Being what it is.
So that means like...
The production for it will be done a lot sooner than what it was initially.
Um...
Oh, it wasn't 42.
It was 48k.
Um...
And I had...
Uh...
It was 48k.
Also...
If there is a country...
Or like a place...
Where...
Um...
It...
It says it's not shippable...
Let me know what...
What places they are.
Um...
Because...
Uh...
I saw someone on Twitter...
It was saying how it wasn't...
Like...
Um...
They couldn't buy it from Philippines.
And then I asked...
Um...
I asked like Gamersubs...
And they instantly added it to...
Um...
They instantly added...
Uh...
Added it to like shippable countries.
Or like shippable places.
So...
If you...
Uh...
If there's like...
If you can't buy it...
Let me know...
Where you live...
But not your full address.
Like just...
Brazil...
Okay...
Alright...
I'll...
I'll say it too.
Write it in...
I'll write it there.
I'll be like...
Ha...
Okay...
Brazil...
Is...
Also...
Not on the list.
I'll write that on right now.
So...
If there's any...
More...
You can also use like my...
Uh...
My tags...
My...
I guess like...
I don't know...
Do I just...
I guess just complain in Doki Bird Day.
Happy rejecting Doki.
Thank you for the...
Aca, aca, aca.
Super!
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
You've been supporting me for so long.
Thank you for the...
Aca, aca, aca.
Super!
Thank you.
Um...
But yes...
Uh...
I guess like...
If I don't see it...
Uh...
Would be the first time Doki...
Doxed the Fath.
Thank you for the super chat, Alan.
Thank you.
Um...
Yeah...
But yeah...
Is there's any other places?
Where you're not able to order it from wherever you are.
Just let me know and then I'll let the GamerStuffs people know as well.
And then they'll fix that.
Oh yeah!
Behind the scenes stuff.
Okay, so... But yes, thank you again for all the support.
Like all the money you guys are super chatting right now is going towards... You know, recuperating.
It's going towards recuperating the amount I spent for...
The Anime Expo concert.
And also going towards my 3D debut.
Digi!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for Magenta.
Super!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Merch is also a great way to support me as well.
That's why I like... I would say like... Merch is also a great way to support me as well.
Because I get a huge cut from the merch as an indie.
So it is also a great way to support...
Support me.
And, you know, you get something in return as well.
So, like, you get something, I get something, which is money.
Okay.
Um, there's no... I believe... I believe the only FOMO drops are... Actually, I'll ask about, like, which one is, like, FOMO items and which one isn't.
Because, like, there are some items that are gonna be there forever, and there's some that might not be there forever.
It depends.
I don't... I'm not that sure.
Because my staff actually handled all the merch stuff.
All I did was handling... All I did was handle the creative side of it.
Like, people I wanted to work with to do stuff like this.
Like, you know, like the artwork.
I chose the artist for all the things I wanted to work on.
Um, Billy, thank you for the aca, aca, aca, aca soup.
Ah, thank you, thank you.
Um, here's my address.
I live an hour from the tomato restaurant, HK.
Happy DNA.
And here's my concert ticket.
Oh, is Hong Kong not that there?
Don't worry, I'll write it there.
Hong Kong is also not on the list.
Okay, there you go.
I wrote that down there too.
Don't worry, I got you.
I got you.
Um, thank you guys.
Okay.
What else?
Wait, what was I talking about?
Oh, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
What was I talking about?
Oh, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I don't remember.
Oh, it is?
Oh, I thought you were like, I'm gonna dox myself by telling you what currency it is.
Okay, then I deleted it.
They don't know.
Don't worry.
Your mistake stays here.
Oh, I can't wait to eat my cake.
Oh, look at this cake, too.
Look at this dragon.
I can't wait to eat you.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Thanks for the show.
Love to see the sloppy sisters on stage.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Um, I, uh, uh, also, yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm new to this Kamioshi thing.
And I've already spent $200 at the AX and stream praying for the meet and greet.
Great to see another bird online.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I'm happy to be your new Kamioshi.
I really am.
Thank you.
And good luck.
Good luck to you.
Uh, can you please do glasses, tired eyes, blushing, and no sports bra.
Uh, that is so specific, Mantis.
Oh, are you Jesus, though?
The only one that can ask me this is Jesus H.
Christ.
I'm sorry.
I don't do it for, for false prophets.
I gotta get Jesus in here if you want it.
Um, oh my gosh, I do love my new outfit, too.
Oh, it's gonna be so hard to choose, um, between, like, what do I feel like today.
And I, there's so many new outfits that, I have, like, so many new outfits cooking in my brain right now.
Um, um, I, you know, like, back then, like, I've always wanted, oh my gosh, like, this is, like, my dream.
I don't know if you guys know this, but, um, before, um, uh, before, like, uh, when I was still a Doki bird, like, I guess, like, four to five years ago, um, um, my, my thing was that I wanted to, like, have so many different outfits and different, like,
skin suits as well.
This was even, I, I, I, Bark Nights will remember this.
I had this idea before it was, like, an Iron Mouse thing, where, like, you know how she has, like, different skin suits from different artists?
I was planning on doing that, like, before she did that.
And actually was about to, was about, like, was talking about my plans and my Bark Nights, like, I think, like, what, six to seven years ago?
And, um, and, uh, I don't remember, like, it was, like, 67 years ago.
I talked about this to my Bark Nights.
I really, I was saving, I wanted to do that as, like, to collect, like, different skin suits from different artists.
Um, and then, like, I was actually, uh, was going to do that because I had a, if you guys looked at my old, uh, my old very first graduation video, um, I had, I had one prepared.
Like, and it was going to be, like, the start.
Like, it was, it was going to be, like, the start of, like, having different skin suits by different artists and just collecting different styles and everything.
Um, and, like, I was about to do it and then, like, I disappeared.
And then, and now, and now I'm back.
And now, now I'm just, I just collect outfits.
Uh, but, like, now it's a little harder to do something like it because, like, back then, VTubing was a lot newer.
So, like, there was no, there wasn't really, like, branding-wise regarding, like, uh, uh, different, like, you know, branding-wise was, like, more unclear.
But, obviously, I don't do, I don't, I'm not going to do that now because, like, you know, I have my brand, which is, like, this, I guess.
Like, I have, like, a brand now.
Um, but, so, uh, so, like, basically, uh, instead of, like, collecting different skin suits, I collect, well, to be fair, I do collect different skin suits, but they're more, like, shitpost.
They're more, like, sorry, oh, my God, it's just, like, I'm so funny.
Sorry.
Oh, my God, guys, I'm so fucking funny to myself.
Um, anyway, um, oh, my God, um, they're more, like, shitpost, like, shitpost skin suits when I do, like, for different artists.
Um, but now I just collect, like, different outfits, and, like, now I just do different outfits because, like, I don't know, branding-wise, it's just easier.
Um, because I think, like, back then, I have an excuse for being, like, well, I'm just a, I'm just a small VTuber, I'm just a small, like, just a small fish show.
I don't really have a brand, so I just want to, you know, like, because I love art.
I love art in general.
And I used to commission so many different artists and supported a lot of different artists before I was here.
And now it's really crazy to see a lot of people draw me for free.
Because I was never used to that back then.
I basically love collecting art.
I love collecting art and I used to commission so many different artists for artwork for me.
And because of that, I was like, oh, I want to collect VTuber skin suits too.
That was another thing I thought about collecting.
Because I have an unhealthy obsession with collecting things.
Depending on what I zero in.
And back then, I was thinking about collecting skin suits.
That sounded so wrong.
I'm gonna skin you.
I gotta catch my...
Actually, like...
Back then, I contacted like two to three artists.
For like, regarding like potential like...
VTuber skin suits and stuff too.
So, yeah.
It's pretty crazy to think about.
Like, that was something I was actually planning.
But now I just want to make very different...
Lots of different outfits.
For different themes and stuff like that.
Um...
Oh my gosh.
I can't leak it to you guys yet.
About like, what kind...
What kind of outfits I'm gonna get in the future.
But I think on...
In 2026, I do want...
To host another outfit contest in the future.
Um...
Because I love the stuff you guys designed for me.
And like, I would love to like...
Um...
You know...
Uh...
Make some of your outfits into like, reality too.
So...
Right now, I can't do it now.
Because I actually have like...
Several...
Like...
Two outfits queued up at the moment.
Hahahaha!
So like, I wanna get that over with before...
Um...
Before like...
Uh...
Um...
Like, doing an outfit contest.
But thank you!
Hey!
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday, Doki.
You always spoil us so much.
Also, you dropped the tomato beanie.
Yeah, my soul is yours.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, I have two more outfits queued up.
Okay, what if I just reveal to you guys the next outfit?
No, actually, no, I'll fundraise for that.
I'm a businesswoman.
I know, okay.
Alright, let me... I'll set up a goal.
Let's see.
Okay.
I'll set up... I'll set up a goal.
Alright.
Oh, it has to be like... Okay, 50.
Okay, we'll do... Orange or higher?
Okay.
I'll make it...
One hour.
I'll reveal...
Reveal the next...
Because I don't have the next skin suit theme.
It's only... It's just business.
Guys, do you want the 3D debut sooner?
You can't keep getting away.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Buy my silence!
Right now!
You can...
You can't buy my silence!
Alright.
Wait, no.
You can't...
Ha ha ha.
Ha ha.
Buy for me.
This is...
Oh, it's an extortion!
You either don't know what the next theme is or if you're very curious and you want to get spoiled, right?
This is for people who want to get spoiled right now.
Bribery.
Yes, if you want to bribe me right now, you can.
I have no idea.
My mama wrote that date down, and I did not ask any questions.
I actually... I don't know.
She wrote that down, and I didn't ask.
I was just like, cool.
Pay to win.
Yes, okay.
But those who were like...
All right.
I know this is like...
It kills your... Okay, I won't kill your immersion.
I'll do this.
Okay.
So, for those who are like...
What the fuck does this say?
Um...
Or like wondering, like, what does this mean?
I don't know.
I honestly don't know.
I just...
I was just like, oh, well, we'll keep it there.
I don't know.
It might be special to my mama, but I have no idea what the date mean.
Okay.
How about accept my breath?
But...
That's basically...
Um...
I don't know.
April...
I don't...
What happened on April 1st, two...
2004, mama?
What happened then?
Okay.
I want to take down my hoodie.
What happened then?
I don't know.
There's so many combinations, dude.
That's the thing.
Like...
I...
It's gonna be so difficult to like...
Choose...
Uh...
Choose like...
Um...
What to use?
Because it's all...
Like, you know, I have summer...
I have the beach episode now.
And I have school episode.
And then, um...
I have, you know, my bounty western themed and everything.
So it's gonna be like...
Super difficult to...
Figure out which one to use for your streams these days.
Um...
Oh my gosh.
So much.
I love all the variety.
I love variety.
Like, right now, I'm like...
Um...
Back then, like...
It was very difficult to like...
Uh...
There was a limit to like...
How...
What you can do...
And stuff.
Uh...
So like...
We had a limit on like...
You know...
What toggle...
Like, the amount of toggles we have.
And especially like...
If it's a complicated thing that we want...
It limits like...
The amount of toggles and stuff.
But now...
Since I'm an indie...
I was like...
I want this.
I want...
I don't have to like...
Pick, you know?
I could be like...
I want this!
And then I also want this!
And I want...
Because it's my money.
Like...
It's my money.
Even like...
You know...
I'd be like...
Oh, I can't pay extra.
Like...
Oh...
Um...
They're like...
No, you have this limit.
And I was like...
Okay.
But now I'm like...
This is my money!
I...
I want this!
And I want that!
And I...
I want to have...
This combination too!
I'm greedy!
I want this!
Welcome to Tomato Farm!
Welcome!
Because I'm like...
That looks cool!
I think I wanted so many things!
And it's why...
Like...
My mama forgot about the...
She did...
She said she finished it!
I think she just...
She just forgot to send it to me!
And...
Um...
And then like...
I didn't realize it!
Because I was so busy!
Like, you know?
Like, I didn't check the file or anything!
I just assumed...
Like, everything was there!
Um...
Because there were so many things I asked for!
You know?
Like...
Like, even for the beach episode!
There was a lot of stuff too!
Like, you know?
Like, I have this...
Sorry, you don't see...
Like, sorry!
He's like a little short!
The greed never stops!
Can the next outfit be considered...
A tax write-up!
Uh...
Robin, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
And here's the second one to make up!
And the other one!
But...
Uh...
He's...
Sorry!
He's a little...
He's a short king too!
Mr. Class President!
Ha ha ha ha!
No, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you guys!
Thank you guys so much for the support!
I...
I really mean it, guys!
Thank you all so much!
Ha ha ha!
Thank you, everybody!
Um...
And as someone was saying, like...
But yes, I do love investing...
Reinvesting into my own channel!
Because like, like I said, I don't know why I'm gonna fall off.
So I'm taking advantage of this, like, as much as I can to like...
Also that, you know, because like...
I feel like VTubing, I don't know if I could do this for like 10 more years or anything.
I don't know.
But like, um, I think like, not just like VTubing, but streaming career.
I always say this before, but streaming career tends to be like a really...
Unless you're like one of the big ones, I guess.
Like, um, the ones that like, are like super fucking big and everything.
Um, for me, like, uh...
Um, I don't know.
Like, whatever I'm gonna fall off.
So I'm taking advantage of doing all these fun things I can with the funding that I have as much as I can.
And doing all these like fun investments into my channel and into you guys.
And like, letting you guys have a great time with me and stuff.
So thank you again.
Thank you everyone.
I really appreciate it.
And thank you for spending, um, your time with me on my birthday.
Yay!
Because I feel like, you know, if you guys weren't here, I'd be spending it alone.
So, I really appreciate it, guys.
Um, for you guys all being here.
Because I would have been like spending my birthday alone.
And I wouldn't have been doing anything special at all.
Just, just go on my day.
But I had a whole day planned for you guys.
A whole day with... together.
Yay!
Oh yeah.
I'll just drop this right now.
Next week, I'm doing a collab with Nimi, Doobie, and Mint.
I'll reveal it on my birthday.
What?
Yep.
I organized a...
Um...
I organized a collab with, um...
Uh, Nimi, Doobie, and Mint for next week.
And, uh, we're gonna be playing Emissionary Zero.
Uh, next week.
Um...
Uh, we were like discussing about games and stuff.
And I brought up Emissionary Zero because it looked like a really fun game.
Because it was also for...
Also, we're like...
For those who are wondering, oh, what about Peak?
Because I know a lot of people are like, when are you playing Peak?
Um, we're playing Peak the week after that with the Sloppy Sisters.
Uh, so...
That's why...
That's why, like...
Um, we never, like, really brought it up.
Like, you know, obviously, um...
People were wondering, when am I playing Peak?
Um, we're playing that with the Sloppy Sisters the week after that.
Like...
So yeah, here.
Here's a little drop of knowledge for the schedule.
I'm bringing back collabs again.
Like I said, now it's more chill time.
I do a lot of solo streams the last couple of weeks and months.
It's because I've been so fucking busy that it's very hard to organize collabs.
Because usually I'm the one, for collabs, I'm the one that reaches out to people.
And when I'm very busy, I don't reach out to people.
That's basically it.
So that's why there was a huge lack of collabs.
Because usually, I feel like VTubers are just a very introverted group of people.
So unless they get invited to, a lot of them tend to do solo content because of that.
And because I've been very busy, I haven't been reaching out to people.
Like even the Chibi Doki collab, like I was the one that I organized that and stuff.
So unless you're like an extrovert or like, I'm not an extrovert by the way.
I just like, I just like, I like doing collabs, but like I'm not an extrovert.
But I also like, but that also requires me to like, I like doing the, I like doing the collabs.
Organizing it is hard.
Also, like, I feel like asking things is like, not that difficult to do.
Because like, I don't know, I guess I'm shameless.
Like, because like, I'm so used to like, asking people and stuff.
Because like, my mindset is like, the worst they can say is no.
And if they say no, then you're like, alright, whatever.
Like, I'm not, like, I get sad, yeah.
Like, I get sad and overrejection.
But like, it's all about taking a shot, you know?
Like, it's just a 50-50.
So, yeah.
So, yeah, I'm looking forward to next week's collabs.
And then the week after that collab.
And then I don't know what the next collab is after that.
I...
Yeah.
Oh, shit, we reached the goal.
Nice.
Okay, you guys bought my, you guys bribed me.
Alright, are you guys ready?
To know what the next outfit, outfit theme is?
It is.
Whoa.
Alright, take a guess though.
Wait, guess.
I want you guys to get, I want you to see what you guys guessed first.
Before I reveal it.
Congratulations, dragons!
Yay!
Congratulations!
Whoa!
You did it!
You bribed me.
Successfully.
Let's go!
Alright.
Oh, one person.
I saw at least one person that got it right.
That got the theme right.
But which one is it?
Alright, so...
Alright, so the next theme...
Or...
I won't reveal...
Like, the design's done.
But like...
The design's done.
The skin suit isn't.
The design is.
Um...
This design is also not designed by my mama.
Uh...
I...
Commissioned someone else to do the design for it.
Um...
You'll understand why?
During the actual stream for it.
Whenever that's...
That is.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Um...
But...
The next outfit theme is...
Um...
Is sleepwear.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Uh...
For...
Good Night Dragoons.
Cause...
It was inspired by...
Good Night Dragoons.
And I will say...
The sleepwear...
is...
Is...
A lot...
More...
Feminine.
That's all I'll say.
Oh...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
It's a...
More...
Feminine...
Design.
So...
Um, that's all I'll say about the next outfit.
I don't know when it'll be done, though.
I don't know when it'll be done.
I only have the design of it.
Um... What if you could bribe... Unless someone wants to bribe me... Unless someone wants to bribe me... I won't say much, but if someone slides something over...
I may be... I may... I won't say much.
No, she can't keep getting away with it.
Name your price.
Okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're a female.
Okay.
$20 is $20.
Jesus, we need you.
Who the... When we need him the most, he's disappears.
Alright.
Anyway, I'll talk about... Um, the behind the scene... The scene stuff.
Um... Speaking of concerts... I'm gonna talk about the behind the scenes stuff.
Um... For... Um... For the... For the concert.
So, okay.
I love... I love the giant ass dragoon that dances with me.
Because it reminds me... Like, I said this before...
But it reminded me of the... Katy Perry.
This is between you and me.
On the black fire.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Jesus died for the sports bra to come up.
Jay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Scott, are you one of the good females?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Five dokelion doublooms under the table for you.
Okay.
So, I love it.
Because it reminded me of Left Shark.
From the Katy Perry concert.
And, like, I... Like, because at first, we were like, is this size okay?
Or do you want me... us to, like, make it smaller?
And I was like, no, this is, like, perfect.
I was just like, no, this is actually so... It's so fucking stupid.
I love it.
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you to the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Here is your bribe, Toki.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
A maid, a nurse, a train conductor, and a bounty hunter.
What do all of these have in common?
Well, you can find them all taking a break at a saloon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, alright, I'll show you guys.
Okay.
Some of you guys were like, I have a special treat for you guys.
Um, regarding Left Dragoon.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
I have... I have a very special treat for you.
For... for Left Dragoon.
I think this is the right one.
Let me double check.
Um, yeah, this is... Okay.
I'll show you guys.
Okay.
Okay, look at...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Look at...
A real person is there.
Look at Left Dragoon go.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Dragoon.
California girls.
Whoa.
Look at this.
Needle legs go.
That's for our entertainment.
No, there is a real person in there.
That's a real fucking person.
Lord, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Great concert, Toki.
I hope I can watch more of your live streams in the future.
And now that I've been watching more of your videos.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
The legs are so expressive.
Wink if you need help.
Yeah.
Left Dragoon.
Go.
Yeah.
Yeah, baby.
But yes, I wanted to show you guys this.
Also, I guess I could show you guys this one.
Okay, so Party Rock originally.
Okay, so also dad was originally going to...
Um, this was a scrapped, uh, one of our scrapped, uh, choreos for this.
Um, so we're...
Shuffling is really hard.
Um,
we had, uh... Oh yeah, that was another thing I wanted to polish.
Cause dad was supposed to be on me during like the last MC portion.
Like he was supposed to like appear during the last MC portion, but like, um, he wasn't there.
So I want to add that in.
Cause you know, I wanted him to be there.
Um, but obviously I didn't want him to dance with me because like, so the dance moves were like, you know, fucked up.
But we had like, so this was like a scrapped, uh, where was it?
Okay.
This was like scrapped basically of like the choreo.
We changed the choreo after I was like, I was like talking to one of my friends about it.
And they're like, no, you have to add the shuffle.
Like that's like so iconic, but like shuffling is so fucking hard.
So like, I'll show you guys.
So that.
I was like, I don't want to do the shuffle.
So, so I was just like, okay.
Okay.
Every day is shuffling.
Yeah.
I'm shuffling.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I'm shuffling.
Let's go.
So, um, I, I, I, I was just like, okay.
And then my friend was like, no, you have to do the shuffle.
I, I, oh my God.
Shuffling.
Sorry.
Uh,
um, so, um, that's why I like, we, it was changed, but I wanted to show that to you guys.
So like, just so you guys know what it was supposed to look like before we went back to shuffle it.
Uh, um, man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I discovered you a couple of days ago and I just wanted to stop by and wish you a happy birthday.
Yay!
Hope you enjoyed your special day.
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you so much for the support, everybody, and for the super chats.
I really do appreciate it, everyone.
And like I said, I really enjoyed spending my birthday with all of you guys.
Alright, more behind-the-scenes stuff that I can show you guys.
Okay.
Where is it?
I like...
Behind-the-scenes.
Oh, yeah.
Also, my neck was broken.
We fixed this.
It was bad.
Yeah, so my neck was gonna be broken, and I was just like, oh, that's not good.
That's not good!
So, thankfully, we fixed that in time.
Also, like, this was the...
Okay, so...
Originally, the sunglasses were like this, but I was just like, I don't like that.
Like, I don't know.
It felt... I don't know.
I wanted...
You know, it was already a shitpost, but, like, I wanted to make it, like, a serious shitpost.
So...
So, the glasses were originally...
Uh, yeah, that was, like, a bit too meme-y.
So, that's why I was...
The MLG...
Yeah, the MLG glasses!
I was like, guys, I don't want...
I don't want to use the MLG glasses.
Because I was wearing that, too.
I...
I was wearing that.
Honestly, like...
I wanted, like...
I was gonna ask if we could keep it on...
Left Dragoon.
But then, like, I...
Because I didn't want to wear the MLG glasses because it looked weird.
I did!
I asked!
Okay, that's something I wanted to polish.
I wanted to ask them if we...
Because, like, I want to ask if we could swap the glasses to my aviators.
Because it makes more sense.
Why the fuck am I wearing a different...
Sunglasses?
And then, they were saying, like, oh, we can't fix that.
Like, that's gonna take us a couple of more days to fix that.
So, I was just like, okay.
Can you just...
We're like, we can add stuff to it.
So, that's...
That's something I wanted to polish, too.
That's...
That's something I wanted to change.
But I...
I...
I changed the MLG...
MLG glasses.
Because I was like, okay, that's...
That's too Mimi.
That's way too Mimi.
Oh, and then...
These are the original cat ears.
And I was like...
Because, like, they showed me this.
And I was like, why the fuck is it bigger than my...
It was so big.
So, we made the cat ears smaller.
Yeah, that's so big.
And it wasn't even the same color.
So, um...
We were able to change that in time, too.
And, like, have it so that...
Like, it was like, you know...
Actually, uh...
Uh...
Actually, like, you know...
My colors.
And also, like...
A lot smaller.
Um...
Win, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday, Doki.
I can hear fireworks outside.
Celebrating your birthday.
Yeah!
Guys, you hear...
If you hear fireworks...
They're celebrating...
My birthday.
Yeah.
I'm all ears.
Um...
But, yeah.
Those are all the, like...
The little...
The little things.
Oh, I'm so excited to...
This is the one...
The one...
The things I'm super excited about...
After this stream...
Is...
Um...
This one here earlier.
My birthday cake!
Yeah!
Cool!
Thank you for the 10 get the sheds!
Thank you!
I'm so excited!
I'm so excited about my birthday cake!
Ah!
Yeah!
It looks so cute!
I'm so excited!
I don't even remember what flavor...
What flavor I picked.
I think I picked Earl Grey?
I think?
I'm pretty sure.
I don't remember.
But...
Look how cute this is!
Ah!
I can't wait to eat you!
Okay, which one do I eat first?
I'm gonna break Longoon's neck!
I mean...
I'm yummy!
Yes, they're all...
It's all edible!
It's all...
It's a chiffon...
The chiffon cake?
Is that how...
It's called?
The chiffon?
Um...
But...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna break the Longoon's neck and go...
You know?
Like that...
Pizza...
I said a pizza man give.
Like the...
The guy that walks up and then like...
Like...
Uh...
Steals someone...
Some...
Like steals something from someone's hand and you're gonna go...
And then leaves.
That's me.
That's me with Longoon.
My son.
Zumi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday, Doki.
Do you plan on releasing an instrumental for your new original?
I'd love to cover it.
It'd make you shine.
It'd make you smile.
Thank you for the super chat.
Zumi, thank you.
Yes, I'm planning on releasing...
You know, all this usual stuff when it comes to original songs.
Um, it's gonna be a while until it's released.
Because, um, I haven't contacted anyone.
Look how they give it a 50!
Get the chips!
Thank you!
But like I said, I haven't reached out to anyone regarding the MV yet.
Um, so, um, that's what's gonna take the most time.
Because you guys might know, when it comes to music videos, I don't...
I'm not a person who goes with a user route with MVs.
Where, like, you know, it's, like, maybe, like, three to four illustrations.
And then, like, um, and then it's just, like, following the tempo and stuff.
I like having an actual story that goes along with the music videos.
Um, I know it's, like, a lot more expensive and a lot more time consuming.
But I like having the experience.
Like, you know, the experience that comes with, um, watching...
Watching these music videos and stuff like that.
Like, I want, like, the...
Um, so, that's why, like, that's gonna take a while in general.
So, yeah, I hope you guys can wait for it.
I really do.
Maybe I'll release, like...
I don't know.
Maybe I'll release the Spotify version or something.
Like, where you can just get the music on Spotify.
Um, but, like, for the MV-wise, uh...
Like, video-wise, I'm gonna...
It's gonna be a while until it's released.
Um...
Yeah, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy birthday, Doki!
Thank you for the concert!
The Forever song was so good!
Thank you!
Oh, yeah.
Speaking of the original song...
The lyrics for that was originally a lot sexier.
Like, a lot more, like...
What do you mean by a lot sexier?
Um...
The lyrics for it was very suggestive.
And then, like, one of them was, like...
Baby...
Something, something, something.
And then I was like...
I don't...
Can we change that?
Hahaha!
That's like...
I don't call anyone baby.
It's okay...
It was like...
I was like...
Okay, we gotta...
I am sorry, like...
We gotta tone that down a little bit.
It's too...
It's a little...
Too sexy.
Hahaha!
But there was, like, other parts in there...
Where I was like...
Oh, wait, maybe...
Okay, I'll tell you what I've robbed you from... I'll let you know what you could have had... Let me see... I just need to scroll it up... Tell us what I took from you... I felt like it was a very sensual...
and a bit sexy.
I was like, it feels a little too out of character for me.
Okay, and then... Oh, I wish?
I don't know.
Oh, wait, wait, maybe?
Let me see.
Let me see if this is the original.
Oh, no, this is like the edited version.
Okay, this is... Okay.
Baby, it's our story.
So, that's like the one of the first line.
And I was like, I don't want to call people baby.
I...
That's what I said.
I was like, I don't want to call people baby.
Yeah, so... No, there's more.
There was more to it.
But that's the only thing I could see because like, you know, there's like chat message previews.
So, like, when they send a link, there's a preview of it.
So, the preview showed the old version of it.
But if I click it, it's the new lyrics.
So, I did... All I could... Like, the only thing I could remember was baby.
But I remember some of the lyrics were like, very sensual.
And I was like, oh, I want to tone that down a little.
So, I don't remember where there was like, the sexy part was.
I don't remember.
But I was like, hello.
We were like, what the fuck?
Doki?
And I was like, hello.
Lord, thank you for the 10 gift of ships.
Thank you.
Doki Bird?
Britannia, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Missed the concert for now.
Do the work.
Hope you have a happy birthday.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
I appreciate it.
Don't worry.
The polish version will be up...
I don't know if it's soon.
But maybe, like, one or two months.
I hope.
So, um...
I'll let you guys know.
I'll keep you very transparent.
Because this one, I'm working close with the...
Um...
I'm working really close with the 3D production team.
So, I'll let you guys know.
Um...
I'll be very transparent about when...
How long it'll be.
The thing is, I don't know if it is one or two months.
Because, like I said...
After my concert, they're working on another 3D project for someone else.
I don't know who.
Um...
So, like, they're gonna be on a different project.
So, then after they finish that, they'll come back to me.
But I'm only fixing, like, a couple of stuff.
So, like, you know...
Like, the full...
The only thing that's, like, full fix...
Is, um...
Is Escape from the City.
So, um...
That's the one that we're, like, fully redoing.
Um...
But other stuff is just minor stuff, too.
So, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
And I wanna add two more songs.
And adding two more songs.
So, like...
Those are, like...
The big fixes.
But...
Um...
But, like...
It should be fine.
Yeah!
What else do I wanna talk about?
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
I love talking to you guys, though.
Wow, wow, wow.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
I know, like, normally people do, like, super fucking long birthday streams.
But, like, I don't have to stomp enough for that.
Um...
Today's been a long day for me, to be fair.
Because I've been up since 10 in the morning.
Um...
I do have, like...
I do have...
In terms of big projects...
I do have, like, one more big project left.
And then, like...
I think I'm taking a small...
Okay, but, like, to be fair...
That big project is all self...
It's, like, self-delegating itself.
So, like...
I don't have to really do anything other than paying them.
Um...
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
So...
Alright, I don't know when that one's gonna be done.
Um...
So, we'll see.
I know some of you might be wondering...
Oh, are you planning to do anything in...
What is it?
Like, the Dragoon anniversary?
The Dragoon anniversary date?
But, like...
That's too...
There's too many events going on back...
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
So, like...
Um...
I don't know.
Maybe we'll just spend time together.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
The Dragoon anniversary.
Um...
And if people are asking about WrestleTuber...
I have not planned that...
In a long...
I have not done any plans for that.
Because...
I've been doing so many...
I mean, I could give you, like, a silly...
VR chat...
Stuff again.
But the only issue is that...
Um...
I don't have any of my...
I don't know...
I don't have any of my, like, those...
Trackers on the...
On the ceilings.
I don't have any of that right now.
I need to buy it again.
And also, like...
I need to, like...
My ceilings are really high.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
I'm just one bird.
My ceilings are so...
My ceilings are so high.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
For VR's chat and stuff.
Um...
Yeah.
Nextie, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Spending time with you is the best present we could ask for.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's, like, stuff I wanted to...
Actually, I wrote...
There were so many things I wanted to talk about.
Because I, like, wrote stuff down.
And I realized I never...
Um...
I never talked about it.
Okay.
Let me see.
Oh!
Funny story.
I can tell this story, I think.
Yeah, I can tell this story.
Okay, so...
Um...
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
So...
Um...
I waited to tell this story.
So...
Um...
I did a sponsored stream.
But, like, you know, I do...
Okay, there's another reason why I do a lot of sponsored streams.
I...
I never...
I don't say no to sponsored stuff.
Because, like, I need...
You know, like...
Pays the bills.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Anyway.
Um...
So, you know...
I was worried that I...
Um...
I was worried that I, like...
Over...
Charge...
When it comes to my rates.
Because before then, I get paid even less.
So, like...
I was always worried...
That, like...
I'm overcharging.
Um...
And, like...
The thing is...
So, I always be, like...
No, I don't know if I should...
Those should be my...
So, I'm always, like, fighting.
Not fighting.
But, like...
Negotiating with my manager on how much to be paid.
Because, like...
I don't know what my worth actually is.
To be fair.
Um...
Due to, like...
I always feel like I'm being...
I always feel like I'm charging too much.
I no longer feel that.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Because of...
Because of one incident.
So...
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
One day...
For one of my sponsors.
Um...
My...
My manager was like, I need to call you right now.
And I was like, Why?
Ha, ha, ha.
You know?
I'm confused.
I was like, Why do you need to call me right now?
I'm still...
I'm working.
And then he's like, No, you need to know this.
And then, um...
And then, like...
I got in a call.
And he was like...
He was like, Look at this.
Ha, ha, ha.
And then, apparently...
One of the sponsors...
Accidentally...
Leaked to us...
The wrong contract...
Of another content creator.
And...
And it showed how much...
They were paid.
And...
And by the way...
They were like...
They...
We were...
We asked like, Oh, should we have...
Should we, like...
Charge this much?
And then, I was just like...
I was like, Oh, man.
And they were like, Oh, we're sort of like...
Out of budget right now...
For Joki.
So, like...
Um...
We're gonna have to pass for that.
And then, I was like...
Oh my gosh.
I'm way too expensive.
I can...
Tell them that I was...
I'm willing to do this sponsor.
So, like...
Um...
You can, like, tell them we're...
We're open to negotiate.
Because it's still like...
Free mo- Like, not free money.
But, like, you know...
I'm streaming a video game.
And I get paid to do it.
Like, for a game.
Like, what if I was planning on streaming that game anyway?
Like...
Like, it's just an hour or two.
Um...
It's fine.
So, I was like...
Okay.
Um...
No, no.
This is a different...
This is a different one.
This is a...
Um...
This is... this is for a different... I didn't... No, you might think I told this story before, but this is a different one.
And now I was just like, oh, just tell them I'm willing to, like... because they were going to pass.
And then they're like, oh, yeah, like, oh, this is out of our... the budget that we have for this promotion.
So, um, so then they're like, oh, yeah, we'll do... I was like, yeah, that's fine.
I'm fine with that.
Like, and then... and then so, when we were gonna sign the contract, the agent accidentally gave us someone else's contract.
And I saw how much they were getting paid.
And they were getting paid.
They were getting paid 10 times more than me.
For 50% less work.
I was like, to be fair, I was like, okay, but, like, I guess, like, they're, like, they're, like, a pretty big kind of creative.
But I was just like, what the fuck?
I was just like...
And then my manager's like, never think you're...
Never...
Never think you overcharge yourself ever again, Doki.
I was like, you're right.
You're...
You're right.
I was just like...
Never think you're getting...
You're overcharging yourself ever again.
And that was my wake-up call.
That was...
That was my wake-up call there.
I'll never...
I'll never fight my manager again about him trying to get me more money.
Yeah.
I was just like, what?
And I was like, what the fuck?
Holy shit!
When I saw that amount, I didn't...
And then...
So...
By the way, my manager, um...
They have, like, an actual real job.
So they do this...
They manage me for the fun of it.
Because they love negotiating.
So, like...
Because it's, like, a good skill to have.
Like, good skill to build on.
So, like...
They love negotiating.
This is, like, for the fun of it for them.
Um...
And...
So, like...
My manager...
Like, they actually have, like, a good job.
And my manager was like...
Was like...
This is more than I'm making.
I was just...
Like...
He's like...
My happiness...
When I make it a year.
I was like...
Holy fuck!
I...
When he saw...
When he saw the contract...
I...
I was like...
Holy fuck!
That's crazy, dude!
That's crazy!
I am...
Um...
Yeah...
Uh...
But yeah...
That's...
That's actually insane.
Um...
Life ain't fair sometimes.
Says the anime girl.
That...
When she was like...
Bye...
Bye my silence.
Um...
Oh yeah!
Speaking of the concert...
I want to talk about the concert a little bit more.
Uh...
But basically...
I just want you guys to know...
I do not have...
Any sponsors...
Going into like...
I mean, you guys are my sponsors.
Like...
The sponsor is me and you.
Um...
But that's why like a lot of concerts...
You see like sponsors and stuff.
You know, like...
Um...
Like lots of sponsors going in.
And...
Uh...
Like to like...
You know, contribute the funding of everything.
So...
I organized all of it myself.
Um...
I had no company.
Managing or like overseeing everything.
It was literally just me.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
And...
And it was all like...
Done...
Within a month.
So like literally...
Like it was just me.
I paid for everything.
And like...
I overseed everything.
Um...
And all that stuff.
So like...
And you guys.
You guys...
Help paid for it too.
Ha ha ha ha!
It's sponsored by...
The Dragoons!
Ha ha ha ha!
Uh...
Let's see...
What else do I want to talk about?
Wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow.
Oh yeah, by the way, I just found out that...
It took the people...
Two weeks to make that...
Peak game.
Like...
I was like...
What the fuck?
Ha ha ha!
That game was only made in two weeks.
You guys know that?
That was a crazy fun fact.
I was like...
Holy shit.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
The new outfit looked so adorable!
And the birthday concept was amazing!
Um...
Hope you had a great birthday today!
Doki, happy birthday!
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat, Phillip!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
Um...
Yeah, I thought I was like...
And it's not that expensive.
I thought it was...
I thought it was really neat that it really...
Like, you know...
It's such like...
Like a game that was clearly made for like...
You know...
They didn't expect it to be like super popular.
They just like...
Made it just for the sake of like...
Um...
Oh, it's just...
It's like a stupid idea.
Let's do it.
Ha ha ha ha!
Yeah.
Um...
Wait, they made a crab Dark Souls game?
What?
Oh yeah, by the way...
Um...
I still find it really funny that the Saja boys from...
That Korean K-pop Demon Hunters movie...
Is more popular than the actual main characters of the...
Ha ha ha!
The movie!
Like...
That defeats the whole like...
Message of the film.
Ha ha ha!
Oh!
They did it!
The crab...
Oh!
They did crab treasure!
That's so...
I didn't know they were that...
They were that company that did it?
Ha ha ha!
The demons!
No!
We fucked up!
The demons took over!
Ha ha ha!
I literally thought...
Bro, like...
Oh yeah, I talked about this in the member stream...
But...
Um...
I was...
Cause I...
Okay, for those who weren't...
There aren't members...
Or weren't there for the watch-along...
Last watch-along member stream...
Um...
The Saja boys are like...
More popular than...
Um...
The Huntrix...
And I thought it was so fucking funny...
Because there's actual like...
Video...
Videos...
Of like...
By the way...
The...
The whole point of like...
The Saja boys...
Is that they're blank slates...
So that you put your own...
Percent...
Head cannons onto them...
And if you look up any of the members...
Of...
That's not the main...
Like the main guy...
Um...
That actually has a fucking personality...
But you put any of the members...
Um...
YouTube...
Any of the members...
Uh...
Of the Saja boys...
Um...
There are videos...
Where...
Where it's like...
Clip...
Clip compilation...
Of...
Like...
Any of them...
So like...
I don't know...
One of them is called baby, right?
Baby Saja boy...
And then...
There is a video...
Of it...
That's two...
Two point...
Wait!
It jumped a million views?
Okay...
I...
What?
So...
They have...
Zero...
Basically have zero lines...
And...
Yeah...
It's...
Two...
Okay...
So this is an example...
So...
This has...
Two point six million views...
And he...
He doesn't say...
He says like...
Two lines...
And...
And there's like...
There's one...
For like...
Each of them...
So you see one for like...
I think the other one is like...
Mystery?
It's like...
Every single time...
Abby Saja...
Saja was on screen...
Every single time...
Mystery...
But it's like...
From the same...
It's like...
Like...
Clips...
And they're literally reusing...
The same clips...
And then you...
The comments are so fucking funny...
I love...
I love the comments...
Like...
Um, what was it?
I was talking about one of the comments in the chat, but like, this is my favorite comment.
Because I was like, they have no personality!
What the fuck do you mean?
They're literally blank slates.
I have to talk about this again, because I find it so fucking funny.
Um, okay, wait.
Okay, where is it?
I need to, like, show you guys this again, because, like, I love, I love this quote.
Wait, this is the wrong one.
Where did I save it?
I don't even know where I saved this!
Oh, I saved it in behind the scenes, in my birthday, but this is my favorite.
I love this quote.
Uh, baby's face, baby's personality, baby's voice.
It's just like, Brokey doesn't, he doesn't even say anything!
He means, Brokey doesn't even have a personality!
What the fuck do you mean?
I, I, I don't know what that means.
What personality?
What do you mean?
Um, he, he rapped.
He said, Gugu got, that one line was like, his entire, his, like, just says his life story.
Um, I just saw the Saja Lincoln, honestly, I get it!
They just have pretty privilege, it's not fair.
Also, um, I, um, I can finally, uh, I did the outline, guys.
I actually did the outline this time.
But, here are all the credits for everything.
I, I'm, I'm sorry if I missed any of the credits.
I've been, like, all over the place.
But, um, you guys didn't see it.
They're 3D animators.
Um, are the people I, I, I...
It's the same, probably gave them personality.
But they're all, like, they're archetypes!
That's the thing about K-pop.
Oh my god, one of my favorite comments about it was just like, It was just like, this is the entire, the movie is the opposite of the K-pop industry.
I wish the K-pop industry...
This is like, it's like, this is like, the idyllic version of the K-pop industry.
But it's like, the entire opposite of it.
Anyway, here are the credits.
So, the 3D animators.
Raman, Aikyo, Septets, uh, 3D rigger for some of the, uh, Dragoon models was Kani.
The sound-a-san, uh, who also did the beach episode, was Mr. Fox.
Uh, Chigo did the under-the-desk prop, where you saw, like, you know, the Dragoon was under the desk and everything.
Um, the K-pop industry, if it wasn't evil!
Yeah, I was just like, I was like, in what world is the K-pop industry, like, this...
Like, like, wow, they get to go on breaks?
What the fuck?
Like, Huntrix can actually go on break and eat whatever they want?
And, and, and meet their fans who are not fucking psychotic?
Like, where is the ethical K-pop?
They get to eat?
Like, the sad...
Um...
Anyway...
Uh...
The...
Debut teaser...
Like I say, Reina did that in like, one to two days...
Like, in like two days...
And like, shout-out to Reina, because my mistake earlier.
Um...
My mom and papa, as you guys know, is Kamame and Sedia.
Uh...
The Isekai...
Isekai video...
Um...
In the middle, with like, the questions and everything.
And like, tomato guide.
I still...
I love this...
By the way, I'm sorry.
I'm gonna...
I...
I love this picture I drew.
Um...
I don't know.
I was like, can we make it look like this?
And I love it!
I wanted it to be more godlike.
I...
I fucking love this.
And this being trying, I did.
I...
It's so good.
Anyway...
Um...
That was...
That was done by...
Uh...
Vermillion.
The wallpaper...
That's the free wallpaper.
That's based off the school outfit.
Um...
It is by Salt.
Uh...
Dragoolin costume.
The reskin was, uh...
Um...
A3.
Uh...
The concert music and the mixing and the original song was by the Asteroid music team.
So I worked with them...
Quite often.
They've done a lot of stuff for me regarding...
Like...
I...
They're basically my go-to...
Mixers for concerts and like...
Singing.
Because they're the ones that know how to make me...
Sound...
Like...
Not a fucking...
Dying bird.
So...
Hahahaha.
They've done a lot of music stuff.
They've done a lot of music stuff for like...
A lot of different companies.
And a lot of...
Actual...
Singers.
So...
I'm really thankful that they worked with me...
Uh...
On things whenever they can.
Um...
The thumbnail was done by...
For the concert was done by Fluffy Cat.
Which you can also get as a free wallpaper!
And then the concert logo was done by Magical Manny.
So yeah, those are everybody that worked on it.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you guys so much.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, this has been like a four hour birthday stream.
Wow.
I just want to say again, thank you guys again.
There were so many gifts and stuff.
I just saw someone made a game and everything.
And they made a little board for a kudo board.
I think that's what they're called.
Or like messages from the fans.
Thank you guys so much.
And there was like videos and stuff.
I really appreciate it, guys.
For like all the work and like the amazing stuff you've drawn and given me.
Thank you guys.
I saw like a game too where it was based on Suika.
But it was basically me and like the Dokiverse.
So thank you guys.
I really appreciate it.
Alright, before we go, let's make a birthday wish together.
Let's blow out the candle.
So this candle is more so of like those, you know, like the ones where it's like...
Where it doesn't go out.
That's the candle that we're going to have to deal with today.
Wait, let me double check.
Maybe I can...
Oh, let me double check.
Oh, yeah.
Alright.
So, yes.
This is like the electric ones.
Yeah, the electric ones, you know, that don't go out.
So we're going to...
Because I'm not allowed near fire for a while.
Okay.
I actually accidentally smoke detected.
Triggered the smoke detection.
Because I was trying to...
What was I trying to make?
I was trying to make something.
And then, like, accidentally triggered the smoke detector.
Because, like...
I don't know.
I don't know what I did.
Oh, I forgot to turn on the fan inside.
I forgot...
I don't know.
I don't know how ovens work.
Let's make a birthday wish before we go.
Because it's been a long Doki day.
Alright.
Let's make a wish together, okay?
I'll give you guys a countdown.
Alright?
Okay, we gotta close our eyes.
Gotta close our eyes, okay?
You can't see what you guys are talking about.
Alright, but think of a wish...
That you really, really want to make.
Alright.
Three.
And then we blow this candle out together.
Two.
One.
Candle's still going because it's electrical.
Now, what was your birthday wish, guys?
What was it?
Oh, you know.
I was trying to make sure your wishes don't come true.
Because you told me.
I was going to be like, Ha!
You told me!
So, now...
Now your wish will not come true.
Aw, I can't fool you guys again.
I can't trick you guys again.
Because there are more wishes for me.
That means...
The less your wishes come true, The more likely mine will.
No, I can't tell.
My crows is thinking with the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know.
I thought you guys might have forgot.
I don't fucking know.
Anyway, guys.
Thank you guys again.
For celebrating my birthday with me.
Like I said.
You guys, right in my day.
Every time I stream.
Or like, every day, basically.
This is a crazy career to have.
Like, you know.
I'm very fortunate to have this career.
I'm very happy that I'm gonna be less stressed now.
I'm happy that I'm gonna be less tired.
Less stressed.
And less overwhelmed.
Now that all of this is over.
Now all, you know.
Like, concert.
And birthday prep.
And all that stuff.
It's finally over.
So, I'm happy.
No longer a little stress ball.
That's something I wanna make.
I wanna make a stress ball.
I wanna make that.
Oh, yeah.
Funny story.
Gamers, those people were like.
So, we all know like.
What you want is like.
Priority merch for us to make.
Because you always say you want all of this.
Like, priority.
But if everything is priority.
Then like.
That defeats the purpose.
Oh, my God.
Because I was like.
I want you to make this.
And I want.
But I keep saying that for every idea I have.
So, they're like.
Okay.
We really need you.
To like.
To actually.
Like.
Um.
Put it in order.
On which one.
Is actually priority.
Anything.
So.
Because we can't make it all priority.
If everything is important.
Nothing is.
Uh.
Oh, no.
Thank God.
Huh.
So, I gotta figure it out.
What I actually wanna make first.
Um.
The one thing I do wanna make first.
Is that.
The miniature plushies.
You know.
I don't know.
Did I show any members?
Or did I show it to you guys publicly?
I don't remember.
I.
Because like.
Everything's been blurring together for me.
But did I show the.
The little like.
The little tiny ones.
Did I show it to the members?
Or non-members?
It was members?
Okay.
I feel.
I feel generous today.
I need to find the.
The little.
The little plushies.
The papa papa.
Um.
Ba-dum-bum.
Ba-da-da-dum-bum.
Oh, here it is.
I feel.
I'll show it to you guys.
So.
This is.
This one is.
I'm putting this in priority.
Because I thought it'd be really cute.
Um.
But.
Uh.
The sweat.
The little.
Those little ones.
The really tiny ones.
And then.
Uh.
And then there's like.
They're gonna be.
They have like the little hoodies.
They can wear too.
So they can wear like.
These little hoodies and stuff.
And everything.
So like.
There's like a dad elf.
You can put this on.
Yeah.
The.
They the 10 to 12.
Yeah.
They are.
So you can like.
Grip them.
I don't know how.
You can.
You can grip it.
And then you can put these little hoodies on your other plushies, too.
So that was the plan.
You can have little hoodies that you can put on the other ones.
And then you can have a collection of them, too.
You have three of them.
So two of them can wear each of the... Grip it, twist it, bop it.
Grasp firmly.
You know the meme where it's just the head popping out of the fist?
That's a priority that I'm making.
But yeah, I hope you guys love all the little gifts.
The outfit reveal.
I wish I could give you guys more.
Usually I'd make a little special gift for you guys.
Or like another special announcement or something.
But I do hope you guys enjoyed what I did today.
What I did for my birthday for you guys, you know.
I had a lot of fun with me and everything.
But thank you all for coming!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you!
I'm gonna call it here, everyone.
Thank you all for the birthday wishes.
Like I said, I wouldn't have been able to do all of this without you guys.
This is actually like a dream job for me.
I don't know how long it's gonna last.
But I hope I can do this for a while.
Anyway, thank you all for being here.
And for spending your time with me for my birthday!
And through all the super chats, all the members.
All the memberships, all the super chats.
All the donations.
All the subscriptions and everything.
I don't think I'm gonna get a million subscribers by the end of the year.
But let's try and make it as close as it can be, okay guys?
And as always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time.
Oh wait, tomorrow!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!